so I want to say something at the top
here you know I was watching another
documentary about flat earthers last
night the second one that I've seen
because I find these I it's it this one
was on YouTube and it's just it's it's
fascinating it's fascinating in the same
way that you know staring at a mangled
car wreck is fascinating but as I as I
thought more about it I realize how
fitting and perhaps inevitable it is
that flat earther ism should enjoy a
renaissance in our day and age which
appears to be what's happening here we
have all of the information in and about
the world available to us and any amount
of critical thought or independent
research will reveal the truth about our
spherical planet to anyone who feels
like expending that sort of mental
energy but the problem is that some
people don't want to expend that mental
energy so they just buy into this we
have become a tree a country of
intellectual tribes I think and the Flat
Earth tribe is especially embarrassing
and weird and stupid but the other
tribes aren't much better honestly and I
think we need to stop and think about
ourselves am i part of one of these
tribes it seems that the availability of
information and the possibility of
becoming really informed and really
knowledgeable is just it's too much for
some of us to bear for some of us to
handle so we retreat into a hive and we
let the hive do our thinking for us I
think that Donald Trump has done a lot
mostly unintentionally to expose this
dynamic in our culture and it's really
been something to behold so those who
are in the resistance tribe they of
course automatically adopt the opposite
of whatever Donald Trump says or
believes whatever his opinion is they
just say the opposite but then there are
those who are in Trump's tribe and they
cling to him like barnacles and they
defend passionately whatever he says and
they believe whatever he says and that's
all there is to it both groups are
united by their vac
hive minds by their inability
unwillingness to think for themselves
that by the way is why I've never been
much of a fan of these of these Trump
rallies like the one that was in
Michigan last night I know that this is
an unpopular view especially from a
conservative but to have all of these
fawning swarms of people who are hanging
on the president's every word and
applauding whatever he says and treating
him like he's like he's a boy band or
something that's not the kind of
relationship that we're supposed to have
with our politicians that's just that's
just not it that's that's not what it's
supposed to be
it is another symptom of the groupthink
disease that is infecting our culture
and we are well familiar with the other
manifestations of this disease college
students you know who collapsed into
puddles of Tears when they encounter an
opposing idea
pitchfork mobs that panic in unison over
the trendy outrage of the day whatever
it happens to be cable news audiences
who sit for hours listening to their
tribes talking points repeated to them
over and over again people who are
flexibly shout labels like racist and
sexist at their opponents and so on
these are all people who are in
intellectual tribes people who don't
want to think for themselves we have
become a nation of parrots at precisely
the moment when independent and critical
examination of issues because is is easy
and and accessible for everyone you know
anyone we carry around in our pockets
these devices that give us access to all
of the information in the world and we
could use this tool to to become really
critical independent thinkers but it's
had the opposite effect scrolling
Facebook or Twitter should be a window
into a diverse array of interesting and
challenging and different and unique
ideas but instead what you get is a
selection of two or three ideas
presented in slightly altered form by
millions of different people now it's
understandable that social media would
become inevitably a toxic
disturbing pornographic garbage cheap we
knew that was going to happen but it has
no excuse to be boring okay it should
not be a boring toxic disturbing
pornographic garbage cheap yet everyone
is saying the same thing about
everything so it is boring the here's my
point the most remarkable thing about
being a human being is that we can think
you know have you we can analyze we can
be critical we can come up with our own
views and ideas and perspectives and
that is such a beautiful amazing
mysterious thing as far as we know we're
the only species on planet earth that
has this capacity as far as we know
we're the only species in the universe
with this capacity we certainly know
that a worm or a goat or an elephant
can't ponder the issues of the day and
and develop their own unique insights on
on these subjects but we can but we
don't you see we farmed that job out to
CNN or Fox or Trump or our favorite
YouTube conspiracy theorist or a
political party or the social media mob
or whatever the goat has no choice but
to be a goat what's our excuse if we
won't think for ourselves if we won't
really think for ourselves and try to
come up with our own ideas then we waste
our lives it would have to be said
although it probably wouldn't be said at
least not at the eulogy that a man who
dies without ever trying to develop his
own ideas has squandered his existence
his entire life was a joke a waste it
was one big wasted opportunity because
he never did with it the one thing that
he and no one else could do and that is
use his mind that's the one thing no one
else can use his mind it was given to
him so his physical death in that case
is much less of a tragedy than the fact
that he never had an intellectual life
to begin with so I think it would be a
good practice and I challenge myself to
do
the same it would be a good practice for
all of us to stop and run a mental
inventory right and think how many of
our thoughts and ideas have been adopted
or inherited or passively accepted
rather than established through a
process of independent inquiry of course
look we have to accept some things on
Authority we have to accept some things
based on a quick and logical assumption
otherwise we wouldn't be able to
function if you if you drive up to a
bridge and and you see a bunch of cars
crossing the bridge you're going to
assume a very quick assessment that the
bridge is probably safe you're going to
drive over it you don't have enough time
to do an investigation of the bridge and
all of that you don't have the expertise
to do it anyway so you have to rely on
the authority of the people who have
built this bridge and the ones who are
supposed to maintain it so yeah you're
that's that's one thing but as for our
deepest convictions and our deepest held
beliefs and values and opinions when it
comes to that we should do our own work
we should we should use our own effort
for those I suspect that almost all of
us could rattle off a list of principles
and priorities that we supposedly hold
but few of us I think could convincingly
answer a very simple follow-up question
which is why why do you think that why
do you believe that and so I think we
need to figure out our why's that's what
we all should do all right Jesse
Smollett
I'm not gonna spend very much time on
this at all but there is there is an
update that I can't just we've been
talking about this all week
I can't just pass over this because
justice Millette has found himself
fortunately for him he has found himself
the sort of shameless hack lawyer that I
I suppose a man like him needs at a time
like this
so his lawyer was being interviewed
yesterday
and she came up with a very interesting
explanation to account for the fact that
Smollett claimed that two white dudes
assaulted him and now they're admitting
that no it was to his two nigerian
friends so i'm gonna play this for you
watch this according to the court
records he Smollett was very clear with
police on the night of the attack that
his attackers were white he said they
had masks on and gloves but he saw their
eyes that he saw the skin surrounding
their eyes was that a false statement so
he just to be clear he only saw one of
the attackers one of them he didn't see
he saw one through a ski mask again he
could not see their body everything was
covered and he had a full ski mask on
except the area around the eyes he did
tell police that he from what he saw he
thought it was pale skin or white or
pale skin was I think what he said and
that was what he and that's why he
initially did have a hard time why did
he say that he could have said I don't
know he could have but this again he's
the ocean died row brothers what are the
chances that that's the case that he saw
somebody with light skin well you know I
mean I think there's obviously you can
disguise that you could put makeup on
there is actually interestingly enough a
video you know I think police said
minimal investigation in this case it
was it took me all of five minutes to
Google you know I was looking up the
brothers and one of the first videos
that showed up actually was one of the
brothers in white face doing a joker
monologue with white makeup on and so
it's not it's not implausible so there
you go
sure that the guys were wearing Joker
makeup and a ski mask that really is it
you can't what you can't satirize this
you can't make any jokes about it that's
how absurd it's gotten I guess they also
you know went to voice acting lessons
and they and because they would have
needed to disguise their heavily
accented voices as well I don't have
anything else to say about that it's
just the stupidity of this case and
speaking of people not being able to
think for themselves if you go online
there are still people who are clinging
to this idea that yeah well maybe maybe
he's made
he's telling the truth and we still had
people the media saying I don't know I
don't know what to think about this I'm
still just it's all so confusing it's
absurd moving on a George and Peele I've
been wanting to mention this for a few
days now Jordan Peele is the director of
get out
and now the horror film us which just
came out I think last week I haven't
seen either movie to be honest with you
but he has announced that he probably
will never cast a white man as a lead in
his films let me read a little bit from
The Daily wire report says according to
The Hollywood Reporter fresh off the
box-office success of the horror movie
us director Jordan Peele said he does
not see himself casting a quote white
dude as the lead in one of his future
films he said at an appearance at The
Upright Citizens Brigade Theatre in
Hollywood I don't see myself casting
white dude as the lead in my movie not
that I don't like white dudes but I've
seen that movie and then of course
apparently that comment drew loud
applause and shouts of agreement and
then he goes on for there you know I've
seen some people complaining about this
comment where he's saying I'm not gonna
cast white dudes I have no problem with
it
honestly they're his movies he can cast
whoever he wants
he's obviously coming from the
perspective of a black man he is a black
man right and so as a director it makes
sense if his actors and his characters
reflect that perspective so I have no
issue with that it would be dumb for me
to have an issue but it's dumb for
anyone to have an issue with that he can
cast who he wants and and his movies are
going to reflect his unique perspective
but it just doesn't work it doesn't make
sense to say that Peele is totally in
the right when he swears off casting
white male leads and we we obviously
know it goes without saying that if a
white director had made the same kind of
comment about how he's only going to
cast white male leads then that person
would never get another job in Hollywood
again so it doesn't make sense to say
that it's okay for Pele to make that
announcement
but then to say that there's something
necessarily wrong with for instance you
know keeping James Bond as a white male
now I don't personally care if they cast
the black guy is James Bond doesn't
matter to me I don't care about the race
of the lead characters of movies that I
watch it makes no difference it would be
lame if they made you know James Bond
and to Jane bond made it made him into a
woman but I don't care what his racist
but what if someone is of the opinion
that James Bond is a white guy that's
who he is that's the character and so he
should stay that way
it doesn't make sense to call that
racist yet to say that peel is not a
racist when he categorically declares
that no white male will ever ever be the
lead in one of his films no matter who
the character is yeah that's that's what
doesn't make sense it's the double
standard and people need to understand
this I think liberals who are used to
going around and blaming white males for
everything constantly complained cutting
down white males demanding that we
apologize for everything and
everything's our fault where are the
villains of history it's like they
really don't understand that you can't
that message is it's just it doesn't
work it's not gonna resonate
you can't expect an entire group of
people to simply accept double standards
they're not gonna do that now I I wanted
to get into an email a little bit
earlier in the show than usual because
it brings up a subject that I want to
discuss I have a bunch of emails I'm
going to answer towards the end of the
show but there's this one that I wanted
to mention here because it requires a
little bit of a longer answer so let me
read the email to you it says hello Matt
you claim to be a Christian but the
Spirit of Christ is not within you you
constantly cut people down mock and
criticized Jesus would not insult and
mock as you do your demeanor is not of
scripture it is of the world I think you
do a disservice
the faith by representing it this way I
will pray for you which by the way the
the whole thing that Christians do where
you say you're gonna pray for someone
passive-aggressively can we can we stop
doing that
that's that's one of my least favorite
things because the thing is you're not
really you know if you're gonna actually
pray for me then then great I appreciate
your prayers but I think most of the
time in that context when someone says
I'll pray for you they're not actually
going home and getting on their knees
and praying for that person it's just
something that they say it's their it's
their way of saying I am I am literally
holier than you that's that's you may as
well just cut to the chase and say that
now I've gotten many emails like this
over the years as it may not surprise
you to learn a mails and tweets and
messages and so on just a few days ago
well here's the setup to that a few days
ago United Airline announced a new
policy that it will officially let you
declare whatever gender you want when
you when you buy a ticket now I'm not
sure that I really want to fly on an
airline run by a company that doesn't
know the difference between men and
women so that makes me a little bit
uncomfortable but I responded on Twitter
saying okay well then I'm gonna identify
his first class I thought you know
that's a loophole right we can identify
as whatever we want then I'll be first
class and someone responded by telling
me basically what this email are said
saying I'm mocking and Jesus wouldn't
mock he would never do that it becomes
clearer and clearer to me that 90% of
the people who say what Jesus would do
or wouldn't do have never actually
picked up the book and read it I mean
actually read it for themselves that's
the theme here thinking for yourself
reading for yourself doing your own work
and I think there are so many people who
go around so well Jesus would never do
that they haven't read it they've maybe
lifted a quote here and there or they've
listened to someone tell them what's in
the book but as far as picking it up to
read it themselves they haven't do that
because if you actually
pick it up and read it this image of the
meek and mild Jesus who would never
utter a harsh word to anyone
evaporates immediately upon actually
reading the book Jesus in the Gospels
calls people snakes vipers hypocrites
liars thieves adulterers fools Satan
so Jesus wouldn't use an insult well
what is it then when you call someone a
snake is that is that supposed to be a
compliment it certainly wasn't a literal
statement he wasn't observing that there
any well they weren't actually snake
that seems to me to be an insult that
Jesus actually used the entire Bible is
filled with scorn and insults heaped on
degenerates and idiots and all over the
place it's all over the Bible that's the
reality now I'm not telling you what to
think about that reality I'm not telling
you how to interpret it but that's the
fact just pick it up and read it in the
Old Testament prophets are constantly
haranguing people calling them
essentially prostitutes and fools and
perverts and on and on and on God in the
Old Testament is famously less than
gentle in his words and actions the
Apostles Paul especially followed in
this tradition Paul has some very choice
words that he uses in fact at one point
he uh he's talking about people who
still advocate circumcision and he says
that he hopes that those people castrate
themselves
all right that's his response to those
people again that seems like kind of an
insult and if I were to ever say that if
I were getting heated about a topic and
I said about the people who disagree
with me I hope they castrate themselves
I would get tons of emails from people
saying yo that's that is unbiblical how
dare you use language like that no it is
it is literally biblical to write in
there
so the polite lovey dovey thing there
just isn't a lot of support for it in
the Bible it's it's it's it's not there
if you read it you'll see that
Christianity is a rough militant
confrontational religion whether we like
it or not that's what it is
any oddest reading of Scripture will
bring you to this conclusion I'll put it
this way the Crusaders had a lot more
biblical justification and precedent for
their actions then did say the Quakers a
lot more now does that mean that we have
carte blanche to go around insulting
people no but it does mean that God
apparently isn't very squeamish about a
bit of tough language because it is all
over the Bible so do I apologize for the
language that I use on this show or on
social media or when I or am I writing
do I apologize for it no because when I
read the Bible I see that there
certainly is a time and place for it and
I would encourage everyone to pick it up
and read it sometime okay before we get
to to some other emails I wanted to
check in with our good friends over at
PETA and I want to show you something
that they posted this week all right now
we know that PETA
I mean they don't really do anything in
terms of actually helping animals their
whole goal is just to get attention to
themselves by these ridiculous publicity
stunts and so probably the best reaction
to PETA with a publicity stunt is just
to ignore them but I'm not very good at
ignoring trolls so here we go and this
week PETA is speaking out against milk
so I want you to look at this look at
this picture this is what they tweeted
it's a picture of a cow in the shape of
a woman very disturbing and the cow is
breastfeeding what appears to be an
elderly man and then the caption says
looks weird right it's what you're doing
if you drink cow's milk raise your hand
if you know that humans shouldn't be
drinking cow's breast milk it was made
for their babies not you alright um
here's my only question I and I've
wondered this about you know vegans for
the people who think that we shouldn't
be
eating cows or drinking their milk and
okay well if that's the case then that
means that the cows shouldn't be on
farms right we're not gonna keep cows on
farms if we're not harvesting their milk
and their meat so all right so what then
let's say that PETA and the vegans let's
say they win and everyone says never
mind don't want hamburgers and
milkshakes anymore let's be done with
that now I personally would fight I
would literally fight to the death
before I would give up hamburgers and
milkshakes but just going wrong along
with the hypothetical for a minute for
the sake of argument let's say we all
swear it off well then what what what do
we do with the cows what happens to the
cows PETA
so what we're Elise all the cows into
the wild and then the whole species goes
extinct in like 15 minutes what do you
think is gonna happen to the cows these
are big dumb docile slow meaty delicious
animals with no defense mechanisms what
does a cow do if you're coming after and
it wants to defend itself it has it
there's nothing I can do the only safe
place in the world for a cow is a farm
that's the only literally the only place
that a cow could survive unless we're
gonna set up some sort of Island for
them cow island and send all the cows
off to cow island but then who you know
they're gonna eat all the grass all the
grass will be gone who's gonna feed them
I mean they need to be taken care of so
it's really for their own good I guess
is what I'm trying to say it's for their
own good that we eat them
that's my point betta all right let's
get to I got a bunch of emails some
really interesting ones so let me get to
those now you can email the show Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com this is from Jake it says good
afternoon Matt I enjoy listening to your
show I and agree with you on most things
you say I appreciate seeing fellow Young
Christian people speak out proudly about
their Christian beliefs and conservative
views if I'm being a hundred percent on
though yours is my second-favorite
podcast to listen to I listen to been
Shapiro's before yours every day how
dare you he is your boss though so you
must have proof that's a good point you
spoke about CS Lewis recently and how
his Lord lunatic or liar argument was
not as strongest theological argument I
being a Christian have obviously heard a
lot about CS Lewis but I never actually
read any of his books I know what you're
thinking are you even a Christian if
you've never read CS Louis contrary to
popular belief it is possible I'm
interested in becoming a real Christian
though quote-unquote and was wondering
if you could suggest a book to start
with if it is too late for me than I
will be grudgingly accept my fate as a
less than average Christian I will
forgive you for having never read CS
Louis I guess this sort of standard
starting point at least for his
apologetic work will be mere
Christianity that's what everyone would
say start with that that's not his best
work by a long shot actually but it's a
good place to start and then from there
I would go to I've talked about the book
many times a great divorce his sort of
vision of the afterlife I think is very
powerful I would read that next problem
of pain deals with his answer for the
you know the problem of pain and
suffering which we've also talked about
on the show recently so I would I would
read those three and then and then
branch out from there this is from I'm
gonna try to pronounce this correctly ly
Lani I think is I'm sorry if I am
mangling that it says my name is Leilani
and I have a few questions for you one
I'm 16 and I live in Hawaii but I leaned
toward the right do you have any advice
on staying alive in a deep blue area as
a conservative I have noticed in my
classes my teachers are openly left-wing
occasionally I will speak up to offer a
different opinion but I usually don't
say anything
is it worth speaking up to how / why do
you think conservatism became
counterculture and 3 I've heard you talk
about vegetarianism / veganism I just
did so I gotta go briefly when you were
talking about how certain animals are
seen as normal to eat whereas others are
not I was wondering given your take on
that would you ever consider veganism or
vegetarianism I doubt you will ever see
this but if you do thanks for eating
thank you for your show I try not to be
a fangirl about anything but I'm a big
fan of your show
hi well great to have you all watch it
all the way from Hawaii I'll try to
tackle your questions one at a time here
so number one you ask if it's worth
speaking up to oppose the insanity you
see around you I'm gonna say yes of
course I think it's worth it
but you should do so with prudence you
know you aren't called to spend every
day all day shouting your opinions into
the sky like I do this is something I
was on the backstage show that's said I
mentioned this that people who are in
this line of work the pundits and
commentators who are in front of cameras
or on the internet I think we often get
way too much credit
because people will say to us oh you're
so you're so brave and courageous you're
you're speaking your mind and sharing
your opinion and well yeah but that's
that's my job this is what I do so I
don't have to worry about losing my job
or having my whole life be blown apart
because I state a controversial opinion
it's literally what I do for a living if
it's not what you do for a living then I
understand that you're in a bit of a
different situation so you have to be
prudent about it one of my favorite
movies which I would recommend watching
which was originally a play it's called
a man for all seasons that's about st.
Thomas More long long story short Thomas
More was a close friend and advisor of
King Henry Henry the eighth King Henry
wanted to divorce and remarry which is
against the rules in the Catholic Church
so eventually the king decided to start
his own church fort for this purpose and
he wanted to start a church basically
just so he could divorce and remarry yet
that church still exists today which
which began for the purpose of divorce
anyway and he wanted he wanted Thomas
More to come out and support this move
but more it was a Catholic and couldn't
do that but here's the thing Thomas More
didn't go out of his way to martyr
himself he didn't go around screaming
from the rooftops that the king is a
heretic you
wasn't doing that he wasn't he wasn't
begging to be a martyr
he took a more prudent approach trying
to advise the king privately going
through those channels and doing
everything he could to remain loyal to
the king while also not betraying his
beliefs there's a great scene in the
movie where he's explaining his his
approach to his daughter and this is
what he says he says listen Meg God made
the angels to show him splendor he made
animals for innocence and plants for
their simplicity but man he made to
serve Him wittingly in the tangle of his
mind if he suffers us to come to such a
case that there is no escaping then we
may then we may stand to our tackle as
best as we can and yes Meg then we can
clamor like champions if we have the
spittle for it but it's God's part not
our own to bring ourselves to such a
pass our natural business lies in
escaping meaning that he wasn't going to
deny his faith or do anything dishonest
or cowardly but he also wasn't gonna
throw himself under the guillotine blade
they'll eventually despite his prudence
he did end up getting beheaded which
fortunately isn't gonna happen to us
these days so all of that to say stick
to your principles never lie for
anyone's sake never pretend that you
believe something you don't speak up
when you feel moved to do so and you
feel like it's the right time but also
at your age and at your station in life
one of your most important duties is to
get through school succeed in that
environment get into adulthood so it's
okay sometimes to say you know I'm not
gonna inject myself into this
controversy I'm not gonna weigh in on
this and yeah look I've been through it
to you you're sitting there in class and
you hear your left-wing teacher say one
lie after another after another it's
very frustrating
but if you're arguing with your teacher
every day all day and interrupting or
constantly that's just not going to be a
key to success it's probably not the
prudent approach so you just kind of
choose your spots and don't feel like
you're being cowardly or something if
you're not constantly
for confrontation number two
counterculture well of course the
counterculture is whatever is against
the general movement of the culture
whatever stands against that tide and
the tide has shifted left rapidly and so
now if you're heading right then you're
going to be counter to it you're
rebelling against it which aside from
the difficulties that we've just have
talked about that come with being
counterculture it's also kind of
exciting isn't it it's it's fun to be a
rebel and especially when you're young
you know young people we don't want to
just I'm gonna let myself in with a
young person as well we don't want to
just typically youth is when you have
that energy to be rebellious and and and
you don't want to just go along with the
flow and so that's the advantage of
being a conservative these days and then
as for vegetarians I guess I just
answered that I respect vegetarianism as
long as you don't shove it in people's
face all the time I totally respect that
I could just never do it I I couldn't I
really could not live that way all right
this is from Nathan says I just wanted
to say I've listened to all your
episodes and during yesterday's episode
when trying to read responses to cardi
B's apology you said your first on air I
can't even which essentially counts as a
type of baptism congratulations you
finally earned your millennial card yeah
Nathan I I guess I I finally understand
that phrase sometimes you really just
can't even even you might not even know
it's not you don't even know what you
can't it's just you just can't that's
the only response possible so I do
finally understand that let's see here
I will do one more all right we'll do
this this is from Rick says Matt I was
following your comments about Calvinism
on Twitter a few days ago I knew you
weren't a Calvinist but I was surprised
by some of what you said do you really
think that God doesn't have the right to
decide who goes to heaven that's what I
picked up from your statements no that's
not what I think Rick I just took it
everyone else up to speed on Twitter a
few days ago we were I don't remember
how it started
I think honestly I was I was on a flight
and I was just entertaining myself by
having a theological argument on Twitter
and so the discussion turned to
predestination which we've talked about
before and I said that I reject the idea
I reject absolutely the idea that God
would send people to hell without any
choice or involvement of their own I
reject the idea that God makes some
people and then Destin's them from heads
to hell from from the beginning you know
from even before their conception
they're already destined for hell
regardless of what they do or believe or
anything and I heard from a lot of
people saying something similar to what
someone who emailed the show yesterday
said which is that well you know none of
us deserve heaven we all deserve hell so
you can't really complain about it
well the word deserve in this context is
a little bit tricky so I'm not you know
I certainly am NOT going to sit here and
say I deserve heaven I'm not going to
say that but everyone deserves hell
automatically so a four-year-old who
dies of leukemia deserves hell wet based
on what what kind of a idea is that do
you really believe that
see that's people say this kind of stuff
I don't I don't believe that you believe
it I can't believe that you believe that
I can't believe that you can look at a
child dying of cancer and say yeah yeah
the child deserves out because that's
what you're saying is that well everyone
deserves hell some people are
predestined now they can't complain
because we all deserve what I understand
that might be your doctrine but does it
actually make any moral or logical sense
to you at all and if it doesn't then
maybe there's a problem you know I can
make sense of the doctrine of hell if
it's something that people essentially
choose of their own free will
they reject God they don't want anything
to do with them and so they don't get
them so I can understand that but as a
destination of eternal conscious torment
that a supposedly loving God makes
people in order to send them to know
because that's how predestination would
work God makes people puts them on a
one-way street to eternal suffering they
have no choice no role that they are
they are made to suffer for all time and
it does no good to say well they don't
deserve heaven because even if I agreed
with that well then why make them in the
first place that's what was the point of
that creation what's the point of
creating something simply to suffer
forever and then you're gonna tell me
that such a God will be loving and
merciful as I've said before you know
come up with a definition of love and
mercy that includes that because I don't
think you can
so I reject that absolutely all right
actually I'll do one more really quickly
because this has to do with the daily
why are the backstage show last night
which was a lot of fun this is from Mike
it says I really enjoyed your discussion
on Daily wire backstage about the
importance of marriage and staying
married you make a great point about how
going into a marriage just as you're
entering adulthood strengthens the bond
and the likelihood that the marriage
will stand the test of time however for
those who do get married later in life
what is your opinion on prenuptial
agreements I know that most people go
into marriage with the best of
intentions but it's difficult not to
look at it in a very practical way in
knowing that there's always a
possibility that it could end a divorce
so when large sums of money are tied up
in wealth and assets that could
potentially be divided it creates a
wicked incentive for divorce if the
marriage is failing
especially when lawyers get involved
I've personally seen friends and family
negatively affected by this and it
terrifies me to even think about not
having a prenup going into marriage I
know this is probably not a very popular
point of view among religious folks but
I am awfully curious what you think
about it so yeah Mike I we talked about
this on a daily why or the backstage
about divorce and everything I
understand the inclination towards a
prenup on as you said a practical level
it does make practical sense in a
certain way we can all say that marriage
is indissoluble it'll be until you
you stay married until the bitter end
until death do you part but the reality
is you can't actually stop your spouse
from up and deciding to run off and
leave you ten years into the marriage
this does happen to people if it happens
it happens so you can't stop it so then
you think on a practical level well
maybe I should just be prepared for that
just in case I don't think it's gonna
happen but in case it does I should be
prepared but I think in the end it just
doesn't that just doesn't work it can't
work you both have to go into the
marriage absolutely committed to it
absolutely determined to stay in until
death you if you have any escape plan at
all any Plan B that will obviously make
it clear that your commitment is not
absolute it might be serious but it's
not absolute and I you you can't go into
a marriage without that absolute
commitment because then at that point
what's the point of the marriage at all
if it's not going to be an absolute
commitment and if you're allowing for
the possibility at the very beginning
that maybe this thing will fall apart
then I would say those why even get
married - just don't get married yeah
without a prenup a divorce might be a
whole lot Messier more expensive more
disastrous and everything but maybe
that's a good thing because maybe that's
all the more incentive not to bail
divorce should be a horrible expensive
catastrophic thing because that that's
what it is this is kind of how I think
about it imagine that you're you're
sitting on a plane waiting while
everyone else boards the plane and
you're sitting there of course praying
that no one sits in the middle seat next
to you and then you see the captain
board the plane wearing a parachute uh
and you say to your flight attendant why
the hell is the captain wearing a
parachute and then she says oh don't
worry it's just a precaution just in
case don't we don't worry
probably won't be needed but in case it
is if things go wrong well the captain
needs to be able to bail out and you
know because he doesn't want to die
obviously well see that that answer is
not going to be acceptable to you
because what you want from your captain
is an absolute commitment to not crash
the plane right that's what you want
from your cabin you want your cabinet to
be absolutely committed to death to the
to the proposition that he will keep the
plane in the air and you want that
commitment even though you know that
planes do crash it does happen it
happened recently it's a tragic thing it
does happen even in spite of that when
you get on that plane you need to know
that that captain is 100% committed and
would literally die before bailing on
the plane and I think in a marriage you
need the same sort of commitment where I
will I will die before I the this ends
with my death and I would die before I
would give up on it
also to extend the metaphor a little bit
let's remember that in this metaphor I
suppose you know if marriage is the
plane then you and the spouse are
captain and co-captain well who are the
passengers that that would be the
children right in most marriages there
are children involved in most divorces
there are children involved well you
know so you're flying the plane the kids
are running around back there there
there you might have a bailout plan you
might have a parachute but the thing is
in a marriage even if you have a
parachute for yourself there really is
no parachute for the kids the kids are
going down with the plane there's
nothing that's going to stop a divorce
from as Andrew claimed and put it at the
back stage last night from blowing up
their world the divorce blows up the
kids world nothing is going to make it
maybe the prenup makes it easier for you
it's not gonna make it easier for them
as far as they're concerned their family
was just obliterated
so that's another reason to uh I think
be careful about prenups and we will
leave it there thanks for watching
everybody hope you have a great weekend
Godspeed today on the bench Shapiro show
President Trump loses it at a Michigan
rally and it's pretty hilarious that's
today on the bench Shapiro show